Anyway. Um, I want to talk about this though,
because I've been talking about it on the podcast and it's just unbelievable.
I, I,
I talked about the movie cats episodes ago when I was in, uh,
Albuquerque and it was way before the movie
was coming out.
I think I found out that day that cats was coming out and I couldn't believe it.
Okay. And I realized that cats is a campy. Cool.
Can't be thing that was supposed to be made as a musical in the eighties.
I think it was made,
which is crazy by the way that it was even made in the eighties
and not the 1840s. Okay. Because you know why,
because it's such a bad idea to have singing and dancing cats around. Okay.
Period. Now,
somehow it hooked in to the culture or the vibe or the
LSD times of the eighties or whatever that it blew up and became a movie
or a, a musical that everyone went to go see.
And there were some jamming songs on it that Barbara Streisand has got famous
singing for one of them. You know what I mean?
Mammaries and that's just a taste. Okay.
People ask if I could sing, I go, you do the mathematics.
Emory means you do the math. Right.
But calculate that my babies.
So they did this thing musical and it blew up now Hollywood being Hollywood and
being on original. Fine. Cool. They also do cool stuff. I get it.
But most of the part,
the money stuff is from the sequels and the reboot and right
now. They thought I love the exec. That was probably like, what about cats?
And then they were like, yeah,
let's make cats not thinking about how stupid it will look
for sure. When they CGI humans with cats,
like standing up upright humans,
no standing up upright cats with human faces and no Teddy's in Cox.
All right. Okay. Oh,
Taylor Swift is gorgeous. Well,
let's take that out of the equation and make her a cat.
Okay. Now they did this movie now on paper. Sounds bad as. Okay.
You know what? Sometimes I don't know. Sometimes I don't know.
Sometimes they Hollywood surprises me. I'm usually right about this.
Did I know speed racing was going to be a tank? Yes. Was it? Yes.
Is it easy to usually tell a tank? Yes. Gemini man. Did I know? Yes.
All right. Uh, so they,
they made this movie and the CG,
the trailer came out and once the trailer came
out, they should have been like, you know what? We're going to cut our losses.
We're not putting any money into advertisement, whatever,
because it was a joke and it looked horrible. Okay. Now I knew it was going to,
I told you months and months.
All right.
It has the craziest weirdest cast. Jason Derulo is in it by
what's. His name from the late night is in it. Find late night show, show host.
Maybe a great actor just seems so calculated that you put them in cats by.
Uh.
Idris Elba. Hey, that guy is too good.
And so is Judy Dench. Don't put them in cats.
Judi Dench did an interview yesterday.
That CA where she said her character was training.
Okay.
Then the end of 2019 goes to Judy Dench. Well, you know,
it's cause my character was trans.
Okay.
Well I just drank and water came out everywhere, but that's how it goes, dude.
When you say stuff like that, I ruined my desk. Now.
That's what she said. Okay. Okay, cool. Judi, Dench, Dame,
Judi Dench or whatever
For sake. When they say like, or sir. Oh, Ian, McKellen's in it. Right,
sir. Ian McKellen and Dame, Judi Dench is in it. Hey, what the?
They're Knights and Queens or whatever. What are you doing?
And putting them in a movie about cats, Ian McKellen's and it just like this,
you know, you know the part where he's against the wall and he's just like,
And you, and he's literally thinking.
It's because of the money.
That's what he was. So this is a movie and Jason Derulo is in it,
which is real dude. It's unreal that they were like, well, we,
you know, he's popular and he's sings and stuff.
So they put Jason Derulo, his handsome in there.
And then Jason Derulo did an interview on a radio station and was like,
Hey man. They said they had to CGI Macaca because it was just too big.
Hey no.
No.
They didn't. No, they didn't.
You know why they didn't CGI out because your is too big.
They CGI to out because it's a car.
Okay.
You mean, if it was smaller, they wouldn't have imagined how weird it would be.
A Jason Derulo came in just like mammaries and he just had a little
nub protruding out of his between his cat legs.
No man. Stop trying to act all R and B and cats, dude.
That's the thing too. When a tries to act all hard,
but it's still in cats. Hey dude,
you're trying to act hard. Like you got a big RMB deck,
but Yarin,
you're singing with Judy Dench,
Dude. Your, your is gone because it's a and this is a family movie.
Okay, bye Dylan. Then, then
you can't have a in a family movie period.
You can't have a character in a family movie period. Jason
decent [inaudible] [inaudible] dude.
You know, because [inaudible], can't see
Janet dude, you can't, that was just the best. And then the interview was like, Oh wow. All right. So you got your
Coxie jot out because okay. Okay. No way.
[Inaudible] I just don't understand.
You know, you're in cats, dude. I'm losing my mind. It's fine.
Why do you listen to this? It's fine.
I, this podcast is like, not yet. And I have to listen, I guess, because like,
it's like a thing and like I make money on it and it's like,
I gotta keep doing it. And like, I just told you that,
like I had sex with a girl years ago and she said, my carcass.
I didn't ever want to do that. Okay. I didn't ever want to do that.
But you made me understand, you know, when Tupac is like,
I was raised in a society and they made me who I am.
That's exactly what the is happening, dude. You're this society and I'm Tupac.
And you made me tell you that a girl had my carcass once.
So what the am I supposed to do now? Happy holidays.
I hope you're listening to this with a family.
I just can't.
What you gone do with that big cat bot.
What'd you go and do with that big cap.
But they had to go to cat school by the way, which is like,
like, they were like, they were shooting band of brothers.
They had to go to weeks of cat school and they were like, Oh,
how cool is it that we got to? We just had to dude,
what are you out of your mind? Just act like a cat
now, catchy. You know, there was some divorced guy that was just like, well, no,
when cats, you know, move around, they move more with their. You know?
You want to lead with the show? Well, imagine I had that part. Oh,
for sake. That's me in the back. What I got to leave?
Can I just walk and walk around like a cat? Well, you want to lead with it?
All right, dude. Are you serious? Jason, are you going to do it?
You're cool with this, Mr. RMBS you're good with it.
I know. Taylor's obviously good with it. And he just, y'all just, you just,
all his obviously into it because he's 50 and just started deejaying.
But come on, dude. Dame, Judi Dench. Of course she is.
She make him call her Dame. Judi Dench, sir. Ian McKellen. Honestly,
he's not even really that into and he's gay and this is a musical.
Um, yeah, dude. Oh,
one fire brought up something on vulture. Ian McKellen learns to sniff.
I don't know what this is, but I'm going to read it.
Dowling set up a multi-step curriculum for teaching actors and dancers.
How to move like a,
it doesn't even say cat dude to move like a gelical cat
Dude. A gelical cat is nothing. Okay.
Also. I bet I know how they move. It's just like a cat.
So get outta here with that gelical.
She started with a basic cat anatomy. She started with basic cat anatomy,
anatomy and behavior, and then made it more gelical no,
I'm kidding. Doesn't say that she started with basic cat anatomy and behavior,
teaching people through videos or lecture lectures about the specific specifics
of cat movement lectures, dude. Hey,
let's try to make it more assholey she would have.
Then she would then have the actors play as cats and instruct them.
Imagine you get that part and you're just licking your wrist next to Taylor
Swift than Judy Dench. And you're just like, what is my life? What is going on?
And then you look over and Jason Derulo is in some tight jeans and off
lights just licking his wrist. And you're like, what is happening?
This is real life that happened. Okay.
She would then have the exercises for instance, to say hello,
by coming up to one another and bump noses. Kay.
Are.
You me? Okay.
Now walk up. Now everyone walk up and bump noses to each other. I go like this,
okay. But I'm doing it with Jason Derulo. I'm not doing with anybody else.
Jason drew was my partner in this. Do you understand me?
Or I'm struck or on per and off,
uh, they learned how to sit as a cat and or how to sniff before they see
to re also they're not cats, dude. They're humans.
So don't need to do that so much busy work shoot the
movie, you know, put it in front of green screen.
I just did a zombie movie and I play a human and I still had to pose in front of
green screen and do all this. So they come in and be my body.
However they want to. And I'm playing a human.
Uh, they react to things less with their eyes and with their ears and noses.
Ian McKellen was apparently especially enamored with this part of the process.
Uh, just imagine, yeah, go down more. Imagine here's something,
you move your head. There you go. Okay. Class dismissed.
On.
The day, uh, on the day we learned how cats greet one another.
I was paired with serene.
McKelly Robert Fairchild said the former New York ballet dancer and Tony nominee
who plays a narrator. Monka strap said, you go 40.
Now all this will be fine. If the movie made a hundred million dollars,
but it made $6.5 million, dude,
this will be made $6.5 million opening weekend. Dude,
my friends make more money than that a year.
This is cats.
Look at this.
You go four inches away from each other and from each other's face and from each
other's faces and just start smelling. And if you like each other,
get tap noses and rub on each other.
I'm four inches away from Gandalf and we're there for 15 seconds.
And then I go for it. I go in and he goes, no, no, no, not yet.
I'm not ready. When I relayed that anecdote to darling, she laughed.
Ian was really very thorough. Hard-working in his cat school.
He said we did a lot of it with him. He's a good actor, man. I mean,
you know, wait, go up, go up, go. The visitor,
everyone needs cat practice. Taylor Swift less. So.
Okay. Keep going down.
How does a gelical cat?
How does a gelical cat on two legs? Does that, is there,
this is a vulture and they left the word out. One problem.
Deli went into the course, got cold,
no matter how much the cast train moving as quickly as possible for legs.
And we trained bloody long,
they couldn't move fast enough to make some scenes work.
Some two legged movement was simply an inevitability
As Jason Derulo put it. We're not just regular cats. We're cat people.
That is true. And I sided with Jason to rely on that. Um,
but yeah, dude, uh, wow.
I just love when they, when the actors like get, so that's the thing, dude,
acting is not that hard. It is. If you're playing the
real guy, the, the guy that you know,
or the girl that's like an actual emotional arc in a scene,
or if you're playing somebody with like, you know, if you're,
if you don't have downs syndrome and Yoplait somebody with down syndrome,
but dude cats just go out there and prance around.
Or like my favorite is when the, when it's like, when it's like, uh,
an army movie and they're like, well,
we're going to go three months of basic training. And you're like,
that's just my numbing dude. It's a waste of time.
I'll study the scene by scene.
Why do I need to be out in the middle of the jungle and not sleep in my bed?
Because I, you know,
because I need to hand somebody a Crock-Pot in a tent in a scene.
It makes no sense. It makes no sense.
Oh yeah.
What does me being at basic training for sleeping over for four,
four weeks? You know what I mean? In the, in, in wherever the.
So I learned how to load a gun. Just teach me how to load the gun.
I already know how to load the gun, but I'll do it for your humor to humor you.
But I gotta be at basic training for four weeks. Like we,
I don't know, man. I just don't. It's like they make it.
It's mostly easy acting. So they try to busy it up.
It's like that school report that it's like, when you come home and your,
and your mom's like, what do you have for work and for homework?
And you're like, add, I got to do a report
Or I got to do a poll. I got to make a poster for a book I read, you know?
And then she's like, okay. And it takes 30 minutes. And she's like, well,
that sounds as long as it takes. And you're like, that's what they wanted.
I'm like, well, take longer on it, make it better. And you're like,
this is what they wanted my own do busy work, man. Like Jen Connery.
She did busy work when, when I was in like fifth grade,
wonder where she is now, man. Maybe she produce our cats. Wow.
That'd be amazing.
Good for her. If she is good for Jen Conrey for producing cats.
aye.
I need, they honestly, I swear to God,
these studios need to hire me to just be yes or no.
Is this movie going to do well, a course not is this no, is this yeah, sure.
Yeah. Did, is this I'll be good at this too? Is this what we're going to do?
Well, well, it's going to do well in Russia. You know what I mean? Why?
Because it got so many like cars and guns in it like that kind of.
Dude. Gelical cat.
I talked too much about cats for real period.